Qdoba is a tough on the lightweight  division because nobody wants to fight  the kid  now I can tell you this nobody will  fight this dude nobody he's knocking  fools out he's an exciting one man he's  a super exciting fighter this dude's  going in there for straight up  violence  Drew Dober when he just signs the fight  he chooses  violence every time yeah no UFC's gonna  reward that this this dude should be I  think ranked in the top 15. even with  this style might get a little dicey when  he gets up top but a Drew Dober versus  Michael Chandler  uh Drew Dober Justin gaichi what  Drew Dober Justin gaichi taking how much  you want to charge me literally whatever  you want to do  whatever you want to do